bonjour à tous merci de nous recevoir en
première page de ce journal de
pétroliers entre en collision sur la
seine entre rouen et le havre il ya au
moins six disparus et deux blessés
graves l'un sandy caire suivi est
circonscrit n'y aurait pas de risque de
pollution avec me ambroise guellec
secrétaires d'état à la mer d'éclat ou
pas déclin en tout cas le mot est très
employé en ce moment soit pour
l'affirmer soit pour le nier nous ferons
le point et nous verrons comment les
politiques riposte à cette idée comment
va la télé elle tourne monsieur elle
tourne pourrait-on dire en paraphrasant
un auteur célèbre le sénateur jean
cluzel auteur d'un volumineux rapport
sur le sujet va répondre dans ce journal
également jean-paul belmondo lauréat du
prix du brigadier pour son rôle dans kin
yves montand qui a été présenté lui-même
jean de florette à new york bon accueil
enfin anthony delon point fine d'alberto
lattuada intitulé une épine dans le
coeur c'était son premier rôle au cinéma
la météo maintenant nuageux partout sauf
sur le sud-est le soleil sera plus
généreux paraît-il demain voilà pour le
sommaire de cette édition est
aujourd'hui mardi 23 juin jour de
détention supplémentaires pour les
otages français au liban
les diplomates marcel fontaine et marcel
carton le journaliste jean paul
kauffmann et notre confrère d'antenne de
jean louis normandin
ça s'est donc passé au en milieu de
matinée six personnes du pétrolier
panaméen vitoria sont portées disparues
deux autres blessés gravement l'autre
pétroliers avec lequel il est entré en
collision le soul you marry un japonais
remonter le fleuve la sem en direction
de rouen
le vittoria lui venait de décharger de
l'essence ce moment précis le pétrolier
japonais l'a percuté de plein fouet
conséquence le bateau panaméen a été
coupée en deux sous la violence du choc
hervé brusini tout cela parce que la
barre de l'un de ses deux navires et
brutalement tombé en panne vers 9h30 le
pétrolier japonais furieux homard ou 140
mètres de long 11 1500 tonnes de
kérosène à bord ne peut plus manoeuvrer
comme si tout à coup sûr une autoroute
le volant de votre
nature se bloquer le bateau valeur
heurter de plein fouet vous l'avez dit
un autre pétrolier panaméen celui là le
vitoria 160 m de l'an il transporte plus
de 17 me mètres cubes d'essence sous la
violence du choc le vitoria est coupée
en deux et puis c'est l'explosion dans
la commune dédiée tout proche de l'as
les vitres volent en éclats sur plus de
4km
nous étions tous comme sonnée a dit l'un
des habitants c'est donc dans une boucle
de la seine que cette collision a eu
lieu non loin de quillebeuf japonais
venait d'anvers pour livrer son kérosène
à rouen le panaméen avait déchargé de
l'essence dans ce même port rhu année
actuellement le vitoria est encore en
flammes sur les 28 hommes d'équipage six
manque à l'appel le capitaine deux
officiers deux pilotes qui est français
les blessés graves pour la plupart
recueillis par le furieux ma rue ont été
hospitalisés et l'un d'eux est brûlé à
plus de 50% pour l'instant selon les
autorités locales il n'y aurait pas de
risque de pollution en ce moment même
tous les moyens la sécurité civile sont
mobilisés pour lutter contre cette
catastrophe
nous avons en ligne de rouen
monsieur jean verbaux vie précisément un
des responsables du port de rouen
monsieur verbaux vie ou en n'étant pas
ce que nous voyons sur ces images que le
ce n'est pas complètement circonscrit
alors enfin vous voyez que quasiment la
phase finale de la chan dit le feu est
maintenant bien souffert maîtrisé par
les bateaux pompes qui sont autour
et on peut considérer que la situation
est parfaitement en main
dites moi s'il ya des risques de
pollution
est ce qu'ils sont tout à fait écartée
comme on l'a dit en fin de matinée oui
les risques de pollution sont écartés
pour la raison que le navire que vous
voyez sur votre écran et des villes il
avait déchargé une cargaison défense à
roy était en train de quitter le port en
naviguant scène vers sa prochaine
destination par conséquent sur le plan
fonds contenus il n'y a pas de risque
que qui était diversement en fait
monsieur géant movie s'agit-il d'une
erreur humaine ou alors le site et se
dire est propice à ce risque
ce jeu en accident de le dire en tout
cas la cause apparente c'est une
amérique part je veux qui s'est produite
sur le navire japonais
les causes précises sont des natures à
déterminer le site en lui même n'est pas
spécialement dangereux il ya to be 6 500
navires qui sert de camp du oui à plus
de 3500 navire qui circulent qui
circulent régulièrement en scène et
on ne peut pas dire que le site en lui
même dangereux d'autres accidents de ce
genre monsieur dans les récentes années
non il n'y a pas eu de dagris dans
important en fait dans les récentes
années de navigation s'effectue dans des
conditions de sécurité importantes
vous l'avez souligné il ya
systématiquement des pilotes qui sont à
bord de chacun des navires qui montent
et qui descendent en scène et qui sont
un élément de sécurité important avec la
couverture radar d'ailleurs qui permet
également de bien organiser tout le
trafic en fait monsieur bové je vous
remercie pour ces explications les
images que vous venez de voir en même
temps que nous bavardions une discusion
de ce sujet avec monsieur verbaux vie ce
sont les images de nos confrères d'ars
faire 3 qui diffuse en direct puisque
c'est la station fr3 qui a retransmis
cela alors continuons sur ce sujet la
navigation n'a pas été interrompue sur
la scène ce matin cette partie de la
scène on vient de voir constitue-t-elle
un un danger permanent compte tenu des
matières transportées à proximité des
villes faut bien rappeler deux choses la
concentration industrielle on sait bien
et très importantes sur les rives de la
seine d'autre part le trafic est
également mais nous venons d'entendre
des consignes de sécurité existent
jacques fiolet la situation du port de
rouen et de la baie de seine est donc
particulièrement dangereuse il y assure
les deux rives du fleuve entre rouen et
le havre
la plus grande concentration
d'industries pétrolière raffineries et
installations chimiques diverses
c'est ce qui explique l'importance du
trafic un des plus conséquents de france
la circulation s'effectue de jour comme
de nuit
rouen est un port de mer ils transitent
chaque jour dans chaque sens plus de 100
bâtiments que ce soit des péniches et
des navires de haute mer qui remonte
jusqu'à roi pour les gros cargos et les
pétroliers
une vingtaine environ tous emprunte un
chenal d'environ 300 mètres de large où
ils peuvent se croiser parfaitement
balisé les règles de navigation sont
très strictes à bord des grosses unités
pilotage est obligatoirement effectuer
par des pilotes du port de rouen ou du
havre qui ne font que ce trajet c'est la
première fois qu'un accident important
qu'une collision se produit entre deux
gros navires sur cette centaine de
kilomètres
alors monsieur ambroise guellec vous
êtes secrétaire d'état à la mer et nous
avons un certain nombre de questions à
vous poser vous avez entendu monsieur
verbaux vie qui viennent de témoigner
sur cet accident loriot il n'y aurait-il
pas trop de bateaux à cet endroit au
même moment en tout cas
non seulement pas permettez moi d'avoir
d'avoir une pensée pour les victimes de
cet accident n'ont rien qui était
totalement imprévisible et est
malheureusement inévitable parce que ce
blocage de gouvernail dont on a parlé
conduit effectivement malheureusement à
rendre le bateau totalement impossible à
manoeuvrer
alors pour le reste non je crois on l'a
dit 3600 navires par an ça fait dix
navires par jour à peu près dans chacun
des sens un chenal qui fait 250 mètres
de large qui est d'ailleurs très bien
entre lui régulièrement entretenus il
n'y a pas de problème pour ces navires
qui sont je dirais de dimension moyenne
je crois que dans le cas général la
sécurité est bien assurée d'ailleurs il
a bien été indiqué que les accidents
sont rares oui c'est vrai mais pour le
friant offre un terreau presse étaient
des accidents très rare aussi mais quand
il arrive c'est une catastrophe ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui mais pour des
transports de matières premières comme
le kérosène et matières dangereuses
inflammable kérosène l'essence s'il n'y
a pas des règles particulières comme
c'est le cas pour les routiers par
exemple si si bien sûr il ya des règles
et savez vous que c'est parce que le
navire est évident que ceci est arrivé
que l'explosion a eu lieu a finalement
gilles en puissance sur les rives ils
s'en sortent bien parce que si ça avait
été plein des noms et non s'il na vi
avait été pleine de ce serait
probablement pas passé grand chose
peut-être une pollution par épandage du
produit mais c'est le fait un bateau
vide
je dirais pas que c'est une bombe mais
il y à des risques d'explosion
relativement à porte dans les images en
direct qui continuent d'ailleurs je vous
en prie ou semi continu louis est ce que
je voudrais dire d'autre part c'est que
à partir d'une certaine taille de
navires l'on rend la partie intérieure
inerte en remettant à gaz comme la zot
qui ne réagit pas si vous voulez dans le
cas particulier de ma vie avait une
dimension inférieure tout de même est ce
que vous ne pensez pas qu'il faudrait
améliorer les conditions de sécurité
même si elle vous semble satisfaisante
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut toujours
améliorer les conditions de sécurité je
les dis lorsque l'accident du herald of
free enterprise est arrivé mais dans ce
cas là il faut connaître les résultats
de l' enquête
naturellement une enquête est ouverte
maintenant pour ce qui concerne cette
collision qui a eu lieu
nous en tirerons tous les enseignements
nous progressions constamment dans les
conditions de sécurité
monsieur le ministre vous remercie
deuxième et dernière journée du voyage
du président mitterrand en basse
normandie aujourd'hui pas en bessin
virer alençon je vous rappelle qu' hier
le chef de l'état avait déclaré entre
autres choses non au déclin de la france
nous reviendrons sur ce thème dans un
instant en effet depuis le début de son
voyage le président de la république
rejette la morosité et le pessimisme la
france dit-il en substance n'est pas
dans la situation désastreuse que l'on
tente aujourd'hui de décrire même
pugnacité dans le discours qu'il a
prononcé ce matin françois mitterrand a
également insisté sur le rôle prééminent
du chef de l'état voici le compte rendu
de notre envoyé spécial bernard pradines
haut on n'a rien sans rien a dit à
nouveau le chef de l'état pour en bessin
où il a rencontré des pêcheurs et visité
des chantiers navals
monsieur mitterrand a rappelé la
nécessité de la justice et de la paix
sociale
un peu plus tard à vivre sous forme
solide estime le président parlera de
l'importance pour l'avenir d'une france
à la fois rassembler et au travail
il ne peut pas enlever nos voisins et
notre pays dit le prince bandar atoubus
doit savoir surmonter ses divisions
crédit commun
je voudrais aussi que le message
essentiel du président de la république
aux français soit celui là il n'y a pas
de fatalité qui nous soit hostile
notre destin est dans nos mains je
voudrais que toute la france sache que
rien n'est jamais donné que tout est
toujours ok et qu'on peut faire
confiance aux français pour conquérir
nos lendemains pour dominer les
difficultés du présent pour rester digne
et richesses et des fastes de notre
passé une fois de plus monsieur
mitterrand avant proposé l'idée d'une
france en technique
le président d'arts et musique vient
d'arriver à l'hôtel de l'enfant ap de
l'étape vivent depuis 1973 date du
premier choc pétrolier le mot crise est
apparue dans notre vocabulaire vous y
êtes donc habitués mais depuis quelques
jours c'est vrai à la publication
notamment des chiffres du commerce
extérieur
on retrouve le mot déclin au coin des
discours des éditoriaux déclin
économique politique de la france point
d'interrogation à cela unanimement le
président de la république vous venez
d'entendre le premier ministre le
ministre de l'économie le président de
la commission européenne répondent
mobilisation générale s'est déclinée sur
tous les tons alors maintenant voyons
toutes ces déclarations raymond parent
tout d'abord en corse appelle les
français à rejeter les affrontements
stériles et les discussions sans
importance mais il réaffirme que la
situation économique est inquiétante
edouard balladur lui à rennes considère
que souffle en france un vent de
pessimisme tout à fait excessif et puis
pierre bérégovoy ce matin a également
commenté l'actualité économique
ecoutez-le
j'ai dit que l'économie française était
en panne autrement dit que le
redressement qui avait été entrepris
jusqu'en 1986 se trouvait compromis par
la politique qui a été menée depuis le
mois de mars dernier mais la france
dispose de beaucoup d'atouts
c'est un pays qui l'a bien sur le plan
démographique
il suffit de mettre un peu d'ordre dans
nos choix économiques d'assurer la
cohésion sociale du pays d'obtenir la
stabilité politique pour cela mieux vaut
se rassembler que se diviser pour que la
france affronte dans de bonnes
conditions
la situation internationale précisément
quelles sont les priorités en fait pour
relancer la machine bien il s'agit de
faire en sorte que l'argent gagné par
les entreprises restent dans
l'entreprise
il faut donc diminuer l'impôt sur les
bénéfices des sociétés
lorsqu'il reste dans l'entreprise elle
augmente et lorsqu'il est distribué le
mot déclin n'est pas apparu au hasard
gérard leclerc on pense qu'il correspond
la publication des chiffres du commerce
extérieur dans un contexte politique on
peut dire fragile ce qui accentue le
pessimisme est pour autant est-il
justifié ce mot que tu es d'abord ce
vent de pessimisme a trouvé
effectivement d'abord sa force dans le
séisme du commerce extérieur et plus
précisément de nos échanges industriels
avec l'étranger il était bénéficiaire de
7 milliards il ya 2 ans de 3 milliards
et demi l'an dernier ils sont
déficitaires de près de 4 milliards en
mai dernier le made in france ne se vend
plus souvent de plus en plus mal en tout
cas on perd elle a dix années de retard
dans l'investissement autres oiseaux de
mauvais augures l' ocde qui pronostique
une france bientôt championne du chômage
au moment où l'italie que l'on regardait
parfois avec condescendance dépasse la
grande bretagne et new talent ajoutez à
cela le gouffre de la sécurité sociale
un livre polémique sur les français
paresseux et puis simplement un
printemps pourri vous pourrez en bouche
et comme les autres les trompettes de la
france en déclin
painchaud est ce qu'il faut pas nuance
est quand même ce tableau bien sombre
aurait absolument la france n'a pas le
monopole du chômage et des soucis pour
ses dépenses de santé elle affiche de
beaux succès avec airbus ariane ou les
programmes informatiques quant aux
français selon une enquête toute récente
du bip y travaillent moins que japonais
c'est vrai mais plus que les allemands
ou les anglais
enfin s'il y a bien perte de
compétitivité de l'industrie française
c'est selon un rapport du conseil
économique et social
moins par manque d'investissement que
par inadaptation de ces investissements
on a trop privilégié les secteurs et les
équipements dépassé et trop négligé les
nouvelles technologies la recherche la
formation les relations sociales
bref on a trop misé sur les machines et
pas assez sur l'intelligence le thème du
déclin tient plus du discours politique
cependant que de la réalité économique
ne l'était il ya il est en partie un
phénomène de mode qui explique largement
la proximité des élections
présidentielles le discours sur le thème
moi ou les déclins remplace l'ancien moi
ou le chaos
quant à nos déboires économiques qu'ils
tiennent peut-être est-ce que leur
apport d'aller d'autres présentent comme
le véritable mal français un sentiment
de supériorité voire de mépris à l'égard
des autres et puis une certaine
inconscience de la bataille économique
dans laquelle nous sommes tous engagés
merci gérard alors l'actualité politique
en france avec déclarations de madame v
hier soir sur france inter oui jean
marie le pen profite de l'image de
division que donne la majorité déclare
simone veil yves chalier a commencé une
grève de la faim il est incarcéré je
vous le rappelle depuis sept mois à la
prison de la santé pour la faire du
carrefour du développement et il veut
obtenir sa mise en liberté
certaines augmentations de loyer sont
scandaleuses c'est pierre méhaignerie le
ministre qui le dit et il demande aux
l'anc aux locataires pardon il vous
demande donc de vous renseigner et de
faire respecter vos droits
enfin jacques douffiagues le ministre
des transports déclarent qu'ils
cherchent les moyens pour sortir du
conflit dans la navigation aérienne par
ailleurs l'intersyndicale d'air inter
annoncent une grève de 24 heures du
personnel au sol jeudi nous allons
reparler d'économies par le biais des
ventes d'art vous allez comprendre pour
soutenir le marché à l'exportation
la france compte beaucoup depuis
longtemps sur ses ventes d'armes à
l'heure actuelle il faut savoir que les
états unis et l'union soviétique se
partagent environ 80% des ventes d'armes
dans le monde
nous arrivons en troisième position nous
sommes talonné par la grande bretagne
mais nos ventes ont légèrement chuté
pourtant vous allez voir au cours du
salon de satory la france est en pointe
dans ce domaine
elle est bien placée par exemple pour li
vente de missiles pour les ventes de
munitions et également pour la
modernisation des armées étrangères
voyez ce reportage de laurent postiers
il s'appelle eric ce qu'il est petit
léger maniable il a été spécialement
conçu pour le combat en ville et il peut
détruire tous les chars de la prochaine
génération
c'est le dernier né des missiles
portables c'est une des vedettes du
salon de satory ça ça n'est pas un
simple aux bulls et une munition flèche
capable de percer à plusieurs kilomètres
de distance un blindage de 50 cm ou un
mur de deux mètres de béton
c'est une autre vedette du salon de
satory mais malgré ces armes de plus en
plus perfectionnés de plus en plus
fiables les exportations françaises
d'armement terrestre tags ou régresse
les clients traditionnels n'ayant plus
les moyens d'acheter ces matériels
souvent coûteux résultat une industrie
en sous-activité qui dans certaines
branches a dû licencier jusqu'à 30% de
ses effectifs une industrie qui cherche
à se diversifier en développant ses
coopérations internationales
dans ce contexte difficile qui risque de
durer encore quelques temps une société
fait l'événement son principe est simple
faire du neuf avec du vieux
vous prenez un char soviétique des
années 60 vous lui mettez un canon de
105 mm un télémètre laser un calculateur
de tir de jour et de nuit vous renforcer
ses protections et vous obtenez un vieux
chars neufs qui a les performances d'un
blindé moderne mais qui ne coûte que 20
% de son prix
ça s'appelle le rétrofit et ça marche
très très très fort alors vous l'avez
compris satory c'est un salon de vente
d'arbres terrestre la joaillerie chaumet
les intéressent kiss à quatre sociétés
dont deux saoudiennes ont fait acte de
candidature la reprise de l'entreprise
en dépôt de bilan depuis le 10 juin
les frères chaume et incarcéré pour
escroquerie parmi leurs victimes vous le
savez albin chalandon et pour la
première fois le ministre de la justice
parle de cette affaire à la télévision
c'était ce matin avec gérard morin je
n'ai rien à me reprocher at il dit
écoutez le ma femme et moi avons demandé
la chaume est de nous racheter des
bijoux ce qui a été fait en 81 5 86
et puis une partie de l'argent qu'ils
nous devaient pour cet achat n'a pas été
payé c'est tout alors je suis créanciers
de la commercial de la maison chaumet
comme hélas beaucoup de joueurs vous
n'avez pas porté plainte le ferez vous
un jour je n'ai pas porté plainte pour
des menaces ou bien simple c'est que sur
le plan juridique je n'ai pas
possibilité de le faire j'ai des
différences commercial et non pas je ne
suis pas une victime benhadj créances
commerciales via un achat qui n'a pas
été payé il exact que votre votre
démission était envisagée à la lutte je
veux pas du tout enfin je suis je suis
prêt naturellement si le premier
ministre considérait que je suis dans
une situation difficile à le faire ça et
moi je suis un homme extrêmement détaché
ne serait ce que par mon âge
alors je suis tout à fait prêt à le
faire mais je n'ai pas de raison de le
faire parce que la situation dans
laquelle je me trouvais très clair d'une
part à titre d'essai de particuliers et
sur le plan du gouvernement et une sur
la justice il n'y a eu aucune difficulté
comment se présente le paysage
audiovisuel français à l'heure actuelle
réponse dans un instant de jean cluzel
sénateur rapporteur spécial des crédits
de la communication comme il parmi les
chapitres les plus importants de ce
rapport les perspectives du
développement des chaînes de télévision
les forces et les faiblesses du secteur
public et enfin cette question le marché
publicitaire sera-t-il suffisant pour
satisfaire toutes nos cours maintenant
précisément monsieur le sénateur bonjour
une question qui nous concerne on va
commencer par le service public et donc
antenne 2 en l'occurrence comment
va-t-on vivre et ceux qui nous regardent
ça les intéresse pas ce que les
téléspectateurs vont-ils continuer à
payer la redevance ou un peu plus cher
ou alors va-t-on vivre avec redevance et
publicité et je crois qu'il faut vivre
avec
redevance et publicité à ce qu'ils
disent à secteur public fonds publics et
à secteur privé fonds privés je réponds
non
non car il ne faut pas que la télévision
publique devienne une sorte de
conservatoire ou de ghettos et il faut
que vous soyez au vent du large et il
n'y a aucun problème pour que vous
défendiez les couleurs du service public
alors comment payer et quoi payer et les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent bien
sûr se pose de questions dont 6 me
concerne je suis très net jeudi qu' il
est indispensable que la chaîne leader
du service public qui est antenne 2
puisqu'il ya deux chaînes services
publics antenne 2
3 que la chaîne leader est autant de
moyens au minimum que la chaîne leader
du secteur privée antenne 2 égale tf1 ou
égale une autre demain je n'en sais rien
pas n'y allait pas égal d'une loi de
l'est devrait égaler absolument en
moyens financiers parce que c'est pas le
cas actuellement
c'est légèrement en dessous le budget de
tf1 est actuellement de 3 milliards 700
millions de francs je parle bien entendu
en francs actuels vous est légèrement en
dessous il est propriétaire de tf1
compte bien augmenter ce budget compte
l'augmenter donc il faudra suivre al
assouad ans filles voilà la redevance je
suis net il faut envisager une
augmentation du niveau de l'inflation à
peu près et je ne crois pas que l'on
puisse demander beaucoup plus
alors comment faire plus et bien d'une
part en se retournant
bien sûr vers l'état pourquoi parce que
depuis une bonne douzaine d'années
l'état a exonéré un certain nombre de
français de leur taxe de télévision de
leurs redevances et il l'a fait au bon
coeur des autres téléspectateurs
ça représente une somme de 1 milliard
300 millions de francs c'est à dire
environ le tiers du budget annuel d'une
chaîne alors je ne pense pas que
monsieur balladur ni monsieur juppé
n'accepte en quelques mois de revenir
sur ce qui s'est fait en une douzaine
d'années ce que je vais proposer
commission des finances et j'ai l'appui
de mes collègues c'est que en un certain
nombre d'années trois ou quatre ans le
compte soit remis à zéro deuxièmement le
secteur publicitaire
eh bien il est certain qu'il faudra que
la loi du 30 septembre
86 soit pour ce qui vous concerne le
secteur public légèrement moduler pour
vous permettre d'obtenir ce qui me
paraît être indispensable une égalité de
traitement financier entre les deux
chaînes leader ce qui ne va pas plaire à
nos voisins paix à me priver
wa pourquoi vous savez il ne faut pas
parler en termes de lutte
je crois qu'il faut parler
complémentarité complémentarité au sein
du secteur public entre vous et fr3 vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous l'avez
montré avec les images de rouen et puis
également 3 et également avec le secteur
privé
il doit y avoir compétition pas
forcément adversité pas forcément
bagarre nanard question de ce secteur
lité de traitement j'imagine que vous en
avez parlé au ministre concerné ils sont
d'accord avec vous non car dans la
démarche
non je ne sais pas s'ils sont d'accord
ou pas excusez moi je dis dans la
démarche je voulais d'abord avoir
l'accord de mes collègues de la
commission des finances a car j'ai
présenté mon rapport ce matin
faisons en sorte que les choses soient
bien régler d'abord le parlement ensuite
le gouvernement et c'est une démarche
que je vais faire dans les jours qui
viennent
bon et bien on en parlera alors monsieur
le sénateur à votre disposition merci de
votre visite et puis alors le rapport il
évolue au milieu comme à chaque fois il
est à la disposition la question que
j'ai posée un de vos collègues quand il
est venu il est à la disposition du
téléspectateur absolument pas dans sa
forme actuelle mais ce matin mes
collègues la commission des finances
ayant apprécié ce document ont décidé de
le faire imprimer
il sera imprimé dans les huit jours qui
viennent et chacun peut le demander aux
journaux officiels ou au sénat il lui
sera envoyé son problème très bien merci
voilà si vous voulez savoir qui est qui
comment va telle ou telle chaîne et bien
vous pourrez vous procurer ce rapport
d'information plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans la rue hier
soir à barcelone pour manifester contre
le terrorisme un rassemblement qui
intervient trois jours après l'attentât
commis par le mouvement indépendantiste
basque eta militaire la branche
militaire
deux heures de défilé pour le cortège
qui scandaient le peuple catalan contre
le terrorisme et une 18e personne est
décédée des suites des blessures
provoquées par cet attentat de vendredi
dernier contre un supermarché de
barcelone la police estime qu'il y avait
au moins vous les voyez 300000 espagnol
au cours de cette marche silencieuse de
protestation contre le terrorisme à
l'étranger encore une nouvelle panique à
bhopal souvenez vous un gaz toxique
avait provoqué la mort de 2300 personnes
1984 et bien la nuit dernière une fuite
de gaz a jeté dans la rue des milliers
de personnes mais la fuite a été stoppée
heureusement rapidement et
l'intoxication semble cette fois ci
traîne et cher nous allons maintenant
parler du procès barbie à lyon histoire
de la vie d'un ss ordinaire aujourd'hui
au procès on évoquera la carrière de
barbie depuis son adhésion au parti nazi
c'était en 1933
jusqu'où ça jusqu'à son arrivée en
bolivie c'était en 1951 et surtout
évidemment son rôle exact quand il était
à lyon prague et parmi les interventions
très attendu de cet après midi celle de
mettre nos guerres il devrait évoquer le
rôle des résistants face à barbie et
décrire le fonctionnement des
différentes composantes de la résistance
jérôme camille y vient de le rencontrer
lors est essentiellement de deux thèmes
une part la résistance et d'autre part
la guerre d'algérie disons que dans les
deux cas j'ai l'intention d'aller
chasser sur les terres de l'adversaire
car il a annoncé la couleur il n'y a pas
de raison de bons en ce qui concerne la
résistance il faut qu'on cesse de dire
que ce procès risque de celle liée ou de
gêner la résistance il n'y a aucune
raison que ce soit en ce qui concerne
les dissensions internes dont on a parlé
que personne n'a jamais caché où que je
sois en ce qui concerne les trahisons
qui ont existé et que personne n'a
jamais caché ya pas de mystère il n'y a
pas de secret il n'y a pas à se défendre
je parlerai de la guerre je parlerai du
rapport rocard je parlerai des arrêts
rendus par la cour de la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de paris
et d'une certaine façon pour montrer que
l'armée française en algérie
même si des crimes ont été commis ce que
la ligue des droits de l'homme a été la
première à dénoncer même si des crimes
ont été commis l'armée française en
algérie
il est monstrueux de la comparer à
l'armée allemande je veux créer des
souvenirs personnels puisque pendant six
mois j'ai été rappelé à la lui allait
comme chef de bataillon des nouvelles de
jean claude duvalier maintenant patricia
et bien le tribunal civil de grâce se
déclare incompétent l'état haïtien lui
demander d'obtenir auprès de jean claude
duvalier réfugiés sur la côte d'azur le
remboursement d'une dette de plus de 500
millions de francs
un incident qualifié de mineur s'est
produit à la centrale nucléaire de cruas
meysse dans l'ardèche sans conséquence
pour l'environnement précise la
direction
la bourse maintenant avec jean le berre
si vous êtes des spécialistes si vous
êtes des boursiers vous savez que la fin
du mois boursier c'est et hier on a fini
par est-il en beauté comment on commence
ce nouveau
moi non et bien william on continue sur
la lancée d'hier dès l'ouverture
l'indicateur de tendance est en hausse
de près de 2%
beaucoup d'affaires autour de la
corbeille encore aujourd'hui hier en
actions françaises s'il est échangé deux
pour un peu plus de 2 milliards de
francs d'actions françaises
la confiance semble revenir ici mais il
convient encore d'être prudent il est
toutefois difficile de réfréner des
pulsions d'achat quand on voit le niveau
de prix de certaines bonnes actions sur
notre tableau nous avons de très belles
hausses comme leroy somer qui gagnent
plus de 10% promodès plus de 6% avions
l'assaut plus de 5% pour les nouveaux
actionnaires paribas est à 459 en hausse
de 8 francs saint gobain à 4 129 francs
elle gagne un franc cinquante et ccf on
est en train de le coter en ce moment
ccf 130 de francs en baisse d'un franc
sur le marché des devises le dollar
monte
non très calmement mais encore de 3
centimes à 6 francs 15 la livre sterling
elle est en baisse à 980 le deutschmark
s'effrite légèrement à 3 francs 33 65 et
les culs recul à peine à 6 francs 92 sur
le marché de l'or le lingot d'un kilo a
perdu 850 points à 87 mille francs et le
napoléon un front à 615 francs
voilà où il vient avec le retour de la
hausse c'était une belle journée pour
s'introduire sur le second marché à la
bourse de paris
c'est ce qu'a fait la société onet la
première société européenne de nettoyage
industriel
on a coté 472 france seulement 6 % des
demandes ont été servis une fois encore
le décalage a été important 75006 en
titre à vendre à 380 francs et 9
millions et demi de demandes
merci jean belmondo jean paul belmondo
lauréat du prix du brigadier 1987 prix
attribué par l'association de la régie
théâtrale à rt dont le jury est
constitué de personnalités du monde du
théâtre belmondo interprète de keane qui
n'avait pas été nommé aux molières je
vous le rappelle et qui nient foot
d'hier est toujours à l'affiché au
théâtre marigny et après les vacances ce
spectacle reprendra dès le 8 septembre
alors georges bégoux a recueilli il y à
quelques minutes les premières réactions
de gens que jean paul belmondo jean paul
belmondo enfin couronné cette fois ci
par un prix de tradition oui les
traditions
et vous dites enfin qu'on aime est
depuis passée j'avais pris à la
fiabilité mais vous aviez le mauvais
oeil pour ses prix toujours du succès
auprès du public jamais de prix passera
d'être avec vous je préfère avoir eu
beaucoup de succès auprès du public et
jamais de prix ceux ci l'avaient jamais
de prix si j'avais que des prix et pas
de sexualité et le prix du brigadier
avant vous il ya eu le poulain jeanne
moreau terzieff peter brook par
l'industrie aussi je vois donc c'est un
prix de tradition un vrai prix t1 10
rebonds pour me rendre au théâtre au
bout de tant d'années de recevoir un
vrai prix de théâtre cuisine est ce que
vous aviez un petit peu d'amertume de ne
pas être dans les césars de ne pas être
dans les molières
non notre monde ont pas du tout parce
que je vais vous dire moi au départ
quand il ya eu des césars jamais été
pour jamais voulu voter j'ai toujours
refusé pour des convenances personnelles
et katia eu les molières c'est pareil
j'avais prévu que moi je ne sais pas non
pas parce que je sais moi je n'ai jamais
d'amertume pas pour ma patrie parce que
les jointures des prix le mérite
ceux qui ont été récompensés cette année
son détracteur il a été les prix 0
d'apple prêcher le bouquet la palper sur
des très très grand acteur qui m'avait
méritait aussi cette palais mais c'est
ce qui s'appelle se faire couper siffler
ça m'étonnerait qu'on n'entende pas la
suite je vous la marque créée par écrit
et je vous la dirai tout à l'heure
maintenant nous allons parler de tennis
parce que si sur notre chaîne c'est
wimbledon mais hier c'était un peu
humide
c'était même un désastre la pluie a
complètement empêcher cette première
journée
et puis les prévisions ne sont pas très
bonnes mais les britanniques prennent
tout cela avec une certaine philosophie
alain cossette les plus courageux sont
restés jusqu'à 6h30 mélancolique sous
leurs parapluies
ils ont regardé tomber la pluie sur les
dix-huit bâches qui recouvrent les 18
courts en herbe de wimbledon
jusqu'à à 6h30 quand l' arbitre du
tournoi est venu leur annoncer
l'annulation de tous les matches
contrairement à ce que la réputation du
pima britannique pourrait laisser
supposer
c'est la septième fois seulement dans
les 50 dernières années du tournoi
une journée toute entière est perdu à
cause de la pluie ce matin chez les
bookmakers
on parie sur le nombre de fois où la
pluie interrompt pas les matchs un
parieur pessimiste ou peut-être
masochistes a même parié 500 mille
francs
que les matchs seraient interrompues au
moins pour quelques minutes tous les
jours et ce n'est sans doute pas
aujourd'hui qu'il perdra son bail
les premiers matchs doivent commencer
dans environ un quart d'heure et avec un
peu de chance les premiers jeux pourront
avoir lieu les premiers jeux mais peut
être pas les premiers matches car on
attend la pluie pour cet après-midi bon
new york m jean de florette hier au
cours d'une première réunissant tout le
gratin new york et le film de claude
berri a été applaudie et ils apprennent
aujourd'hui plutôt favorable et ce ne
sont pas des tendres les journalistes
new yorkais du spectacle il monte en
lui-même assuré le service après vente
comme le disait si bien simone signoret
et c'est paul nahon à new york qui a
interrogé yves montand il a également
recueilli sa réaction à la mort de fred
astaire
l'amérique new york
il monte en connaît un effet plusieurs
fois il a chanté ici dès hier soir 7 et
jarrett mann et des sources qu'il était
venu présenter au public américain au
lincoln center
le temple des arabes
les critiques sont unanimes pour nous
est l'oeuvre de radium
maj par claude berri que le new york
times parle même ce matin de shed on
peut affirmer écrit encore le journal
ou jean de florette est un des films
elle n'en avait jamais vu depuis de
nombreuses années plusieurs centaines
d'invités à cette première je les avais
tous pays entre 100 et 200 dollars la
place de cet argent a été versé
directement la recherche contre le sida
comment suivre aussi particulier peut-il
être apprécié les américains puisque
vous avez plus dur aussi français
peut-il précise damien parce que
précisément il est réellement français
qu'il n'essaie pas d'imiter ce que font
gêne à mousse c'est bien je joue à l'est
des poursuites de voitures que ne soit
en la violence je sois d'aller dans les
coups de feu tout s'efface un goût dans
les pensées des jeux comme apaisée jolie
dans des films d'action
tout d'un coup sûr une respiration il
joue un dima est une image du pays
qu'ils aiment bien et il range tout une
langue superbe animation pagnol kern
française vous avez l'impression que ce
genre de film peut plaire au public
américain parce que c'est quand même
éloigné des standards des états unis
c'est grey l'instant si un film comme
moteur de martin guerre à que marché aux
états unis est très fort
ainsi bien plus éloignée est prévu qu'à
ses patientes du public américain
j'ai l'impression que ça commence
elles étant entourées féliciter a dû les
montants charmeur montant qui de loin
reste l'acteur français le plus connu et
le plus apprécié aux états unis et pour
terminer cette page cinéma et ce journal
anthony delon avoué aujourd'hui que nous
avons une belle affiche avec votre
premier rôle au cinéma c'était dans une
épine dans le coeur on a beaucoup parlé
de chronique d une mort annoncée c'est
vrai à ses sorties à cannes mais là
c'était votre premier film alors appelez
moi à l'époque comment alberto lattuada
qui est un grand du cinéma italien vous
avez contactés eh bien il m'a contacté
comme tous les metteurs en scène contact
des acteurs ce père qui l'a appelé mon
agent et m'a demandé de venir à rome
pour faire les essais sauf que vous
n'aviez rien fait de particulier sauf
que je n'avais carrément rien fait du
tout alors y est c'est quoi comme on
appelle ça le feeling en anglais c'est à
dire qu'il avait le sentiment que vous
pourriez rien il avait le sentiment que
je correspondais à son personnage au
jeune garçon donc de l'épiné dans le
coeur et qu'il pourrait mener à bien le
film avec un acteur débutant comme comme
je l'étais à l'époque alors à l'époque
vous aviez quand même pris des cours de
cinéma on en parlait il ya un sens quand
on voyait il monte à new york
longuet quand j'ai fait le film de la
toa d'âge ne met rien c'est entre le
lattois da et la chronique que j'ai pris
des cours
quelles raisons vous ai dit il faut que
je prenne des cours parce que là je
m'embarque sur un terrain inconnu non
jeu mais oui enfin si vous voulez je me
suis dit de toute manière comme dans
tous les métiers vaut mieux la prendre
pour le faire bien et apprendre à jouer
la comédie c'est c'est prendre des cours
mais en principe on n'apprend pas en
cours de route on apprend avant non pas
forcément
pas forcément il y en a qui apprennent
avant il y en a qui apprennent en cours
de route
sans d'ailleurs prendre de cours vous
avez l'exemple d'acteurs et voilà donc
bon on va regarder un extrait de ce film
et après vous me direz comment vous êtes
sortis de cette expérience
voici un extrait donc d'une épine dans
le coeur d'alberto lattuada
mais c'est la femme mystère et pourquoi
n'es tu pas venu à neutrons en et vous
saouler finir mon livre je me suis dit
elle m'aura donné rendez-vous comme ça
au contraire un peu voilà
quoi tu n'es pas nulle autre jour
je vais te faire attendre un peu
comme ça c'est plus beau
je trouve pas que c'est plus beau
je suis content de ce but
non
alors vous l'avez deviné site une
histoire d'amour entre un ce garçon à
cette jeune femme qui reste très
mystérieuse poser bien ça oui c'est
d'abord un film très très romantique
c'est l'histoire d'un gros d'un d'un
jeune joueur de poker qui tombe amoureux
d'une paysanne qui pensent en fait les
met réellement alors que la chose qui
prime dans sa vie c'est le poker et
comme pour beaucoup d'hommes le jour où
elle le quitte pour un espèce de
quasimodo accidenté il pense encore une
fois être réellement amoureux d'elle et
c'est de la récupérer ne peut pas la
perdre
alors pour ce rôle de joueur de poker
c'est un rôle de composition vous aviez
déjà non jeu ça m'est arrivé de jouer au
poker est latent et en petit enfin plus
jeune plus jeune et vous aviez deux
endroits là oui il ya deux ans il ya
deux ans
comment vous êtes comment vous êtes
sortis de cette première expérience vous
ai dit bon bah ça va je suis comédien
ouhlala il temps de prendre des cours
comme je me suis dit voilà j'ai vu
d'abord comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure ça n'a rien à voir avec le rose
hill un personnage caractère rien du
tout je suis sorti de cette expérience
j'ai vu le premier bout à bout qui n'est
pas un montage et je suis sorti de la
salle de cinéma de projection suffoquer
sercus musini ouhlala faut que je parte
tout de suite à new york pour prendre
des cours faut que je travaille parce
que et c'est terrible c'était la
première fois je me voyais à l'écran non
plus n'était même pas un montage
définitif c'est un bout-à-bout et puis
j'ai compris qu'il fallait que je fasse
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de jaloux
j'ai entendu dire récemment d'ailleurs
mais je suis encore qu'un passant
quelque chose comme ça un passant dans
ce métier est ce que vous considérez
maintenant que vous êtes un comédien à
part entière c'est votre vrai métier
celui vous continuez à faire un pas son
nom jeudi un débutant
pour l'instant je fais ce métier et
j'espère
oui continue à le faire mais toujours
pas je vous ai mis une fois chez notre
ami pierre tchernia j'étais pas sûr que
vous aviez envie de continuer je me dis
et redis il fait encore quelques
expériences qui a pris sera le bilan
non mais à cette époque là j'étais
d'abord très nerveux parce que le film
n'ait harel et sortir à cannes que je
veux m'attendais au pire au niveau des
critiques beaucoup de choses donc c'est
un peu un peu tendu hélas pour la sortie
de celui là ça va mieux
oui bon on a été fait avant le rosier
après c'est un peu un mélange de danse
et nous on verra le temps du canton sera
fille patricia beaulieu demande était ce
qu'il y à un acteur français qui est
pour vous un modèle aujourd'hui qui est
une référence non un modèle une
référence non pas du tout il ya des
acteurs que j'aime et j'ai depardieu par
exemple mais j'ai pas de référence le
projet prochain avant que on se revoit
n'ont pour l'instant rien de signé
très bien mais bombe à bientôt donc
anthony delon je rappelle donc ce film
une épine dans le coeur film d'alberto
lattuada avec anthony delon et sophie
duez la mettiez au matin avec josé dans
la pierre c'est toujours aussi mythe
peut-être chose et non beaucoup moins
mais sort mais toutefois l'effet est
avare de ses rayons de soleil en
revanche c'est températures elles sont à
la hauteur de la situation
c'est à dire digne d'un début d'été
voici le temps qu'il fera cet après midi
les nuages en fait de wimbledon et leur
pluies seront sur le nord-est du pays
sur la moitié ouest du pays les nuages
seront de moins en moins nombreux au fil
de l'après midi il y aura du front
soleil sur le sud-est demain c'est à peu
près le même scénario
regardez excepté que retenait bien que
les nuages seront moins nombreux plus
nombreuses sur la moitié n'a beaucoup
moins nombreux sur le sud ouest et tout
à fait inexistant sur le sud-est après
dissipation des brouillards les
températures les voici
elle oscille de 16 degrés c'est la plus
petite la tempe un taux minima sur le
nord jusqu'à 23 degrés à bourges voyait
qu'elles sont en hausse par rapport à
hier 19 degrés à limoges pour le sud est
jusqu'à 28 degrés 28° à nîmes qui
décidément depuis trois jours détient
des records de chaleur
voici donc demain retenez qu'il y aura
c'est mieux merci jausiers vous savez
que ce soit une très belle soirée cinéma
sur antenne 2 parce que nous vous
proposons en souvenir du célèbre
comédien fred astaire disparu hier après
la diffusion du film d'alain resnais
l'amour à mort et bien car charnière
vous propose un film de mark sandrich
qui s'appelle charles widom ça se
traduit en français par l'entrepreneur
monsieur petrov c'est ce soit alors avec
fred astaire et ginger rogers
maintenant je vous dis au revoir on va
se quitter en images avec quelques
images des films deux espèces de poux
pour dix films de fred astaire voilà on
vous retrouve demain mon après-midi
merci nous avoir reçus